a cidade das caldas o óleo chegou
idealizado pela ceal e fino ypehú também
já passou uma bela equipe se uniu para
lograr a nossa vida em frente ao parque
numa sala do incluída é que está tudo
bem eu queremos a entrada e com tanta
boa disposição é normal que deu uma
gargalhada é um lugar de toda a gente
com atividades para participar
aqui ninguém senta em frente e ajuda as
idéias a já a cesta tema escrita
criativa para exercitar o pensamento e
com muita alegria temos também
musicoterapia é que o tempo passava o ar
porque nos sentimos felizes e olha é uma
boa ação que ficará para sempre no nosso
coração
olha é também um bom exercício para
fazer com calma e pra sempre saber se o
que lhe vai na alma poema do saara coito
masters 1000 reais
antes de falar nome da história do olha
eu queria falar do lugar eo garoto foi
uma mulher que na china os séculos era a
deusa é mas foi uma mulher que saiu dos
padrões não fez aquilo que estava
previsto uma mulher fazendo aquela
altura ela pintou compôs música e e
também ter fundido há quem diga que ela
também foi responsável pela medicina na
na idade média
foi uma mulher que normalmente ao
estavam sendo nos motores dos frate e
ela fez o seu próprio mosteiro e fez a
sua própria forma de estar contra aquilo
que não deve ter sido fácil contra tudo
e contra todos mas foi depois respeitada
é para amargar mais sobre ela aqui olha
eu acho minha fantástica mas não vou
largar crie só neste momento fazemos uma
pausa porque deve haver sempre uma pausa
da nossa vida em momentos durante o dia
durante a semana durante o miss tantos
anos e eu estava que criança que agora
um silêncio interior e vamos escutar uma
música que foi composta pela yuka música
por favor
o vôo
i e ii
nós somos corpo e espírito
a arte é espírito logo nós somos corpo e
arte e temos que ser alimentados por
essa arte trabalhava com essa arte em
2003 faz dons 11 anos eu era diretor
administrativo financeiro de uma empresa
de formação profissional era olha que
faltava trabalhar e o cava só na que eu
nunca é o objetivo que tinha entretanto
foi diagnosticado um cancro e eu acordei
para a vida
comecei a pensar a questionar o que
estava aqui fazer o que nós estamos aqui
a fazer todos nós e eu como o motor pelo
que fiz um um novo posicionamento e pra
lá entrar na piscina convencional foi
procurar outras formas do que eu pudesse
encontrar um sentido para a minha vida
fui contra o rec e outros grupos o rec
foi muito importante nessa altura não
podia dizer à minha família nem familiar
nem amigos que queria fazer aqui porque
é uma coisa super estranha mas digo é
que também não ajudou imenso a sentir a
sentir uma melhoria a seguir aos
tratamentos de radioterapia mas fui
conhecer muitos grupos uns continua a
dar outros pai porque também é perigoso
certas coisas que não são é quando
estamos muito mal às vezes criamos
podemos ir por caminhos que não somos
mais próprias também é este também não
quis ir mas também te prende tive um rio
paraíba observar que os grupos
normalmente a uma entidade grupo e
normalmente às vezes a identidade do
grupo não há identidade ninguém que o
grupo simplesmente foi criado à imagem
de todos e como se relacionar se calhar
também sempre mérito próprio saber quem
doer para trás em grupo e também fazer
um trabalho mais individual porque não
pôde nem continua a não ser isto começa
a se também o grupo e entretanto como
sair pela arte comecei pela arte e
comecei a fazer curso de teatro educação
musical escrita criativa
agravo história dar tudo muito
superficial mas é que o filme algum
sentido e o que experimentar isso e e
com qualquer pessoa tem um problema
oncológico não quero fugir dela seguir
quer ajudar outros tentam lógicos e eu
decidi ajudar com a minha experiência e
foi que com sul em 2010 o olha que é
também comissão como estamos podemos ver
apoiar doentes oncológicos e familiares
gratuitamente envolvem toda a comunidade
também uma prevenção primária para a
doença
olha é basílio acaba por ser a aquela o
que a construção interior que vai fazer
com que tente em contato com organismos
internos e possa ajudar a transformar
interior mente ou mesmo encontrar
algumas áreas que deixasse para trás o
que poderás encontrar um novo sentido
também pela arte
calço quem sabe mas basicamente temos
várias atividades permanentes e o que
vou destacar o componente psicológico
não vai ver nem fotos nem outras roupas
para mostrar que com maria lourença
psicóloga em que ela para além dos
doentes oncológicos tamanho da companhia
crianças anunciante ou familiares com os
de pessoas tenham fugido neto do cancro
portanto basicamente temos pilotos
criativa contemplação ginásio semente e
design de aulas de design também entre
outras num conjunto nós temos que
apoiamos no posicionamento
normalmente a pessoa tem um problema
oncológico e tá mal mas poxa é seguir a
vida normalmente e foi o que aconteceu
o estudo parte do princípio de que o que
aconteceu a mim eu tô ajudar a chance
como como eu entretanto achei como
aconteceu na minha experiência
ok já passou o problema não vá seguir a
sua vida a minha vida já não é a mesma e
não sei mesma pessoa não consiga
encontrar aqui eu tenho outra vez
já não quero aquilo que você não faz tem
tempo pra mim então nós estamos aqui
para ajudar doentes oncológicos que
tenham a passar o problema e que depois
é seguir o problema
dt jogo mas virou problema teria passado
o problema
a duas provas que o caracteriza o cancro
o cancro é magni ah ah ah e uma
catástrofe individual que taxa
individual qualquer que taxa que exista
uma cidade na região no país pode ser
pequenino e 6 grande mas há sempre uma
coisa uma destruição sitrans muitas
coisas e então no campo também é uma
destruição interior
mas como existe uma catástrofe nós temos
que construir e normalmente o que
fazemos
vamos tentar encontrar alguma coisa que
queremos que volta a ficar ou que já não
faz sentido já não vamos reconstruir nós
vamos construir coisas novas e por isso
nós temos que saber quem somos nós temos
que nos encontrar e todos nós temos algo
cá dentro que faz o que faz é que nós já
vimos aqui vá também já temos ouvidas
nas palestras entre os nós devemos fazer
aquilo que nós temos a total aptidão o
tal sentido que nós somos prêmio tenho
convicção que nós fizemos há muito a
fazer muitas coisas mas é uma coisa que
só nós podemos fazer nós somos únicos e
se nós formos o que nós somos emitirmos
isso que nós somos e fazemos o que somos
seja em que área for ou seja a de
maneira que for nós estamos a contribuir
para um mundo melhor porque é muito
fácil e ela precisa ter fácil o mais
difícil e nós encontramos quem somos nós
e arte à educação pela arte ajuda essa
tal descoberta e muitas vezes
encontramos coisas iam surpreendente
mesmo que vamos encontrar surpreendendo
surpresa das surpresas no meio desse
caminho de descoberta anterior
então nós no fundo pegamos na pessoa e
vamos trabalhá lá em vários domínios e
depois basicamente como através das
ações permanentes segunda a sexta-feira
exista atividade escrita criativa
contemplação de música meditação e
relaxamento apoio psicológico e outras
transição da terça quase que eu estou
sabendo então fazer depois outras ações
pontuais e experiência
vamos o fim das pessoas envolvendo a
comunidade empresas e instituições
na altura pensei sim rio numa pessoas
crítico de áreas diferentes que não
tinha competência para fazer e e em
femininos e eu pensar como é que devemos
fazer para começar um projeto porque não
precisa que eu sentido de algo de muito
triste do que os ambientes dodô em são
cosme chorar e não sei que não é nada
disso que mais teve que fazer então
decidir e fizemos uma primeira sessão
fotográfica valorização pessoal não é
que surgiu surge porque durante contínuo
muitos dias no hospital internada por
vários motivos complicações que tive é
meu irmão vavá maquiagem
então vá uma triagem para enquanto
estava lá deitada e que o tempo fez
sentir melhor e era um som brote então
pensei realmente nós quando olhamos
quanto um doente oncológico quando se
olha avesso o pior senso piores nós não
tocamos lá no centrinho aquela mãozinha
que nós temos cá dentro da motivação do
paixão do índice ágil seja através pela
imagem para o outro os outros sentido
criar de ajuda muito
entretanto tocamos lá é aquela luz que
nós temos vem pra fora vem posterior e
quando nós olhamos para nós como é
quando estamos com essa luz aumenta a
nossa autoestima encontramos entusiasmo
digamos da vida são injeções vida
o que nós fazemos então aqui na primeira
sessão mas não ficamos porque fizemos a
segunda portuguesa sessão fotográfica em
a maioria aqui até 12 mudas de roupa foi
ótimo
é ela estivesse na altura fez 50 anos e
com uma mulher de 50 anos e é sempre
complicado em qualquer idade mas com 50
anos depois nas fotos que tinha sentido
a família posto em causa e até os
problemas todos quantos se viu nas
chefias ela comentou realmente tenho
boas que fiz custou imenso mas também
depois deste ano ea proposta de jorge
magalhães fizemos a testar avançam
fotográfica que foi surpreendente
vamos melhorando à medida que as coisas
vão
é com uma sessão fotográfica
pedimos às pessoas como é que era a
música que estavam qual é que era a o o
o personagem que queriam fazer e fomos
para o museu do hospital aqui nas caldas
para fazer umas fotos que foram também
umas trabalhadas como podem ver e que
foi uma chuva foi frente foi maravilhoso
e quando que as pessoas iam sendo
fotografada fotografadas ouvir essa
música que os que estavam mais e
equivale a um entusiasmo e uma vivência
imaginação ficção e só souberam que
podem ser que o que quiserem ser voltar
a ser voltar a viver e voltar a ser o
que quiserem ser do lado direito temos a
luísa que é uma história extraordinária
luiza há um ano atrás tinham dito que
não podia fazer a que não perdia há
meses de vida ea luiza disse que tem que
fazer alguma coisa vamos deixar a vida e
arroz à vida e foi pro olha e nós temos
as ferramentas não fizemos mais nada só
ela fez tudo por ela e ela hoje agradece
o olho porque não fosse o hotel tinha
ficado nos fan e possivelmente não tinha
sentido a doença tinha consumido e
portanto por isso é que nós estamos aqui
a rosa miguel queria ser cleópatra o
caio foi outra e depois teve surpresa
depois em casa quando viu a sua foto
desta forma o museu realmente o exterior
do museu é bastante gratificante bom
para fazer a valorização pessoal é muito
importante pois já tivemos várias
conversas abertas com o criador de moda
pedro batim e aqui é um exemplo da
contemplação música o local onde eu
encontrei a irrigar que eu não conhecia
realmente não conhecia e que os pais nem
por ela e pela história dela
temos também a escrita criativa de que
surgiu que saia com o poema que nós
ouvimos entre no início foi pela sarah
oculto por cônsul é criar o bichinho da
escrita ou desenvolver esse bichinho da
escrita do qual ela já tinha que foi
através da escrita criativa que
desenvolveu mas sua vontade de expressar
através da escrita e nesse momento é
nessa altura escrevi um livro
que se que faz através de poemas e
versos que conta o envolvimento que
aconteceu com ela no que sejamos também
banho através da expressão pela escrita
depois em várias atividades fomos até a
provisão
tivemos que design catarina rola
vamos tendo várias atividades também já
fizemos o dia da criança no hotel sana
que depois não recebemos dinheiro
advertiu para um fim de semana para um
casal uma pessoa doente oncológica
vamos tendo depois temos o yoga que
também outra atividade que ainda vasco
semanalmente que tem lá também pessoas
com problema fomos para os centavos
fomos eu fazer várias atividades entre a
experiência do golfo
o workshop da escola de hotelaria sempre
um grande personagem papel de nós
vários workshops almoço solidários
sempre pronto para nos ajudar a escola é
um rival assim for vamos também academia
de música para o vivaci música no centro
comercial faz muito bem
também tivemos o apoio do balanço é lgbt
neste caso o tamanho do desafio uma uma
aula de música
uma aula de dança porque ela queria ter
aquela aula de dança alguém soubesse
realmente avançar ea antes de pôr a
operação teve ativa aquela aula e ela
conta que estava na maca e crise a que
eu queria sair na maca e o que sentia
era aquela outra música o produto estava
a dançar um tanto tempo podemos
encontrar outras formas também espera
agora encontrar a pensar numa maca uma
coisa dessas é porque marco realmente
não temos que escolher fazer coisas
antes de ir por mo pressão para cruyff
quando fechamos os olhos tivéssemos a
imaginar coisas positivas vai fazer
certeza a diferença pois temos várias
atividades temos o porto também dá mais
eu acho errado o que ajudou nestas
gravações de que ouvimos anteriormente
vários workshops coaching com vanessa
gomes que tivemos um surto a ida da jóia
juliana alves no natal mesmo natal
outra jóia que trago hoje lilian nal
sempre me apoiar
obrigada e também temos várias o
workshop os cursos e atividades
temos pois o tamanho ou a mocidade mais
uma vez
a escola que a escola oficinas e todas
as mulheres é que com o espírito que nós
tivemos porque tem que haver sempre uma
cor não é imposição olha os peões vão
ser por aqui porque a notícia preto e
branco não é não não deve ser nesta
altura que vemos nós somos um projetar
associção retrai clube uma sucessão de
1923 quando abriu a porta e que nós em
vez de fazermos uma sucessão olha e
integramos o projeto na associação
tivemos este último esta última
atividade do escopo do rotary e de cores
de neste verão ea seguir a próxima vai
ser com os postais antigos de dos lions
estamos também fazendo a pressões
vamos fazer também precisa em casa das
pessoas e oferecemos também coisas
fizemos a opção do golfo azul com o
carregado é solidário e fizemos a
juntamos as câmeras do bid caldas
associação comercial e de espanto como
fomos para a vila natal fizemos vagina
também 2003 o vittorio pasta existem
homens só é menos e no preço entanto e
que fizemos há também ações de toque com
o tempo um carro contava pensam mais um
minuto estava em obrigada em que está
agindo foi feita com e forçava quitar
toda a falar isto custam quem ficou as
mesmas pois segue e esteve de visita é o
óleo tenha expressão da vida
tivemos várias chances sessões fizeram
individualmente e em notas mais uma vez
que é mariana ea mãe que também teve um
problema e o amor é e superior e
fundamental em tudo e não é nula mechas
rumor é muito fundamental para qualquer
situação e na vida de cada um é maria
neves também fez já fizeram também a
ilustração do livro de poesia que
editámos o editor também temos outro
livro editado pelo esgoto que foi dos
pensamentos que eu acho que foi
escrevendo mensagens fez um com com os
amigos e entretanto fizemos também conta
com o esgoto que quer parceira que faz
parte do turismo agora estão ficando
cada coisa do tempo das férias roupas
o turismo nacional não existem em
portugal e juntamos o a parte da cultura
e do turismo o conceito olha e fizemos
três jogos em casa fizemos várias
atividades acontecerão várias zonas da
cidade e este ano voltamos tivemos a
nota máxima em 2003 e voltarmos faltar
onde mais um grupo este ano em 2014
mudamos um pouco mais mais ou menos no
mesmo conceito e volta para onde vamos
ter 2 grupos temos o fundo à época era
dirigida pessoas estejam olha para
medicamentos deslocações e estadias para
fazer sempre para que ela prossiga na
memória de todos
entretanto teve um prêmio e estejam
comprando sente se mais confortável
porque eu fiz realmente um projeto de
vida completamente diferente que estava
delineado para mim
temos uma das causas podem ter tanto
conhecer lá na sala no próximo interval
e falar com marisa rocha que a mentora
de que fez de desenho uma das caldas
agora imaginem que nada disto tinha
acontecido e eficácia passava aqui muito
tempo para além daquilo que nós nos
vimos agora vemos agora é o muito mais
coisas e e agora vamos imaginar que não
tinha expulsado tenha pelos ruídos das
pessoas que os eua estão botas continuar
continua aqui fazer isto tua vida e que
embora não tinha nada não tinha fazia
sentido pra mim
e olha tanto existido e nada que eu
tenha acontecido e as pessoas que
expressaram por ser elas próprias
tiveram a oportunidade de expressar
quando joão tomás fez pensar não tinham
se passado e nada disto tinha acontecido
mas não nós estamos cá por conjuntos
movemos o mundo e experimenta de ser
provada a pena obrigada